THE ASSEMBLY SESSION IS CALLED
TO ORDER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GLORIA NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR CURRY
ALLEN ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO SERVAN SAYS
CHAU CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DAHLE. DALY.
EGGMAN FLORA. FONG.
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MASUCCI. NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SOLACE
SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL. WALDRON WEBER. WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND
REVEREND BOB COSTA.
REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS YEAR. I'VE RECEIVED MANY
NEW YEAR'S GREETINGS FROM
CLASSMATE FRIENDS FROM GRADE
SCHOOL TO GRADUATE SCHOOL.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM REMARKED THAT
THIS IS A MILESTONE YEAR FOR US.
WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS MOST
WROTE.
THIS WILL BE THE YEAR WE WILL
TURN SEVENTY.
WHEN WE WERE YOUNG THIS WAS AN
UNIMAGINABLE AGE.
AND NOW WE ARE THERE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I TURNED FORTY.
I WISH THAT I COULD BE THIRTY
AGAIN.
I'M SURE THAT IF I AM FORTUNATE
TO REACH EIGHTY.
I WILL BE WISHING I COULD BE
SEVENTY AGAIN.
I'LL BE WISHING I COULD RELIVE
MY YOUNGER DAYS.
THE POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE IS
THAT WE MUST TRY TO THOROUGHLY
ENJOY AND APPRECIATE. BEING
WHATEVER AGE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
THIS TIME OF OUR LIVES WILL
NEVER BE HOURS TO LIVE AGAIN.
WITH ALL OF ITS CHANGES AND
CHALLENGES.
LET US TRY TO COMPLETELY AND
THOROUGHLY MAKE THE MOST OF
LIVING THIS DAY TODAY. JUST AS
WE ARE.
WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
LATEST LIVE NOT TAKING FOR
GRANTED THE DAYS OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
FOR WE ARE LEAVING TODAY. DAYS
WE WILL LONG TO RELIVE YEARS
FROM NOW.
NUMBER ONE.
THE KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THINK HERE. I AM BY YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TODAY'S PLEDGED WILL
BE LED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
READY SALUTE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY JANUARY
EIGHTH.
DAHLE MET AT ONE PM ON WILL
KEVIN MULLIN
BUT TEMAS SENATOR CALDERON MOVES
AND MISS STIRRED DALY SECONDS.
THAT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR IT ILLNESS AND
FRATERNITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MULLIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIM
GRAYSON.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMON TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
LIMON RADIUS GIPSON AND LACKEY
TO.
THE GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM FIFTY TWO S. B. SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO LEYVA TO THE ENACT A
FILE. CLERK WILL NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE NOTICE REMOVAL OF ITEM A
TO AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
NUMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
TODAY FROM GIRL SCOUT TROOP
THREE ONE TWO SIX EIGHT IN
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA SOME
TERRIFIC REPRESENTATIVES THE
TROOP LEADERS AND LADIES FROM
LAS LOMAS HIGH SCHOOL. THEY'VE
COME IN TODAY ON A DAY OF
ADVOCACY TO ADVOCATE FOR MORE
STUDENT SEATS FOR CALIFORNIANS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM SOMETHING WE ALL WILL
KEEP FIGHTING FOR TOGETHER.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
TROOP THREE ONE TWO SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
MADAM SPEAKER. I AM PROUD TO.
RECOGNIZE THE FOURTH GRADE CLASS
FOR MY DAUGHTER'S ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STAR KING ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL FROM OUR PATROL HILL IS A
FRANCISCO YOU WANT TO STAND UP.
THEY'RE THEY'RE HERE THIS IS.
SOME OF THE VERY FIRST VISIT TO
THE CAPITAL.
SO JUST ONE WELCOME THEM THANK
YOU
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ITEMS FORTY THROUGH FORTY THREE
RECONSIDERATION WILL BE
CONTINUED.
THIRD READING OF ITEM FORTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN.
WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM FORTY FIVE.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE LOW MOAN.
THE SLIM MON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE ITEM.
AS ILLEGAL SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE BY
SELLING THEM REALLY MOAN AND
ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
SOME A MEMBERS AMONG. THANK YOU
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE UPDATES
REFERENCES IN THE EDUCATION CODE
TO THE FEDERAL ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY EDUCATION ACT
AS AMENDED BY THE FEDERAL EVERY
STUDENT. SUCCEEDS ACT
IT ALSO REPLACES OUTDATED
REFERENCES TO THE NO CHILD LEFT
BEHIND ACT THIS IS A SIMPLE
TECHNICAL BILL THAT ALIGNS ARE
EDUCATION CODE WITH THE FEDERAL
EDUCATION CODE. ALL PRIOR
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
SEEING NO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELEVOTES I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES
.
ITEMS FORTY SIX TO FORTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY NINE HR
SEVENTY ONE CAP
EURO THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY ONE BY
SOME THE MEMBER CABALLERO
RELATIVE TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COVER EUROPE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO PRESENT
HR SEVENTY ONE.
WHICH CELEBRATES JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
THE FORTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
ROE V. WADE.
ROVI WAY DECIDED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE WAS A PREP PIVOTAL
SUPREME COURT CASE THAT SECURED
EVERY WOMAN'S RIGHT TO ACCESS AN
ABORTION. DESPITE THE COUNTLESS
ORGANIZED MOVEMENTS TO REVERSE
AT FORTY FIVE YEARS LATER ROE V.
WADE.
DECISION STILL STANDS STRONG.
THIS RESOLUTION URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT.
AND DEFEND THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS OF WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WHEN OPPOSITION
ARISES. HR SEVENTY ONE ALSO
RECOGNIZES PLANNED PARENTHOOD AS
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
PROVIDERS IN WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE
SERVING THOSE IN NEED FOR OVER A
CENTURY.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD NOT ONLY
PROVIDES HEALTH CARE SERVICES
FOR WOMEN. AND MEN TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH BUT ALSO
OFFERS EDUCATIONAL SERVICES AND
PREVENTIVE CARE.
IT IS CRITICAL TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OPERATES IN
RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA OR
ACCESS TO SERVICES CAN BE SCARCE
AND COSTLY. THIS IS A TRULY
COMMENDABLE ORGANIZATION AND I
AM PLEASED TO RECOGNIZE THEM
TODAY. SO MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN CELEBRATING HR SEVENTY ONE
WHICH INCREASES AWARENESS OF THE
VITAL SERVICES THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN AND MEN RELY ON AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. AND ALSO DEFEND THE
RIGHTS OF WOMEN ONE FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO IN ROE V. WADE THANK
YOU AND I'D LIKE TO HOLD THE
FIRST ROLE OPEN. FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS AS
WELL AS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ITS ROLE AS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FORTY SIX CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS WOULD KNOW OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE ALL THOSE.
MISS
MISS WALDRON FOR WHAT REASON DO
RISE WITH LIKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE.
THANK YOU WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
HOLLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY NINE
KNOWS TWENTY THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'LL RETURN TO MISS CAVIAR FOR
GAS INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT GIVES
ME GREAT PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE.
BE.
PARTICIPANTS OF ALL FIRST OF
ALL PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHO HAS
BEEN A IN OPERATION FOR A
HUNDRED YEARS AND CELEBRATES
THEIR FORTY FIVE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY. OF THIS YEAR BUT
ALSO ALL OF THE PARTICIPANTS
BETTER HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OUT BETTER IN
THE GALLERY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND UP. WE'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING.
MS LOW MOAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS
AND WE DO HAVE SOME GUESTS HERE
ON THE FLOOR WITH THIS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO START OFF BY
INTRODUCING NIKKI SCOTT. NICKY
WAS FIRST A PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PATIENT NEED IN ABORTION CARE
AFTER RECEIVING TRUSTED CARE SHE
WAS INSPIRED TO BECOME A PLANNED
PARENTHOOD SUPPORTER BEEN A
PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES
INTERN AND NOW LIFELONG. PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ADVOCATE.
LISA MIDDLETON LISA IS A PALM
SPRINGS CITY COUNCIL MEMBER SHE
WAS THE FIRST TRANSGENDER
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE COMMITMENT
TO FAIRNESS EQUALITY AND
CIVILITY. SHE IS NOW IN
SACRAMENTO TODAY AND REMINDS US
WHAT BEING HEARD AND TRUSTED
SHOULD LOOK LIKE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
ALLIE LARDER ALLEY IS AN ACTRESS
KNOWN FOR HER COMPLEX POWERFUL
FEMALE CHARACTERS INCLUDE IN
LEGALLY BLONDE HEROES AND
RESIDENT EVIL FILMS MOST
RECENTLY. ALL THE START IN THE
GROUND BREAKING TV SERIES PITCH
ABOUT THE FIRST FEMALE MAJOR
LEAGUE PITCHER. OLLIE LOVES
BEING A MOTHER OF TWO AND USING
HER VOICE TO ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN'S HEALTH.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE HAVE
ZOE DEBT. ACTORS SO YOU DON'T
SHE HAS STARRED IN SEVERAL FILMS
THAT IS UP AND IS A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND WOMEN'S HEALTH.
WHEN SHE'S.
FILMING IN STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY IS THAT WE OFTEN FIND
HEALTH CARE CENTERS TO THINK
CLINIC STAFF FOR THEIR IMPORTANT
WORK. ZOE IS COMMITTED TO
SPEAKING UP FOR SOCIAL CAUSES
AND WAS NAMED THE MAX MARA FACE
OF THE FUTURE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY WOMEN IN THE FILM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US ON THE FLOOR TODAY
MOVING BACK TO SECOND READING
FILE ITEM ONE THROUGH THIRTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL SIXTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FIFTY WITH
AMENDMENTS FIVE NINETY FIVE AT
THE MOMENT SIX.
AMENDMENTS NINE HUNDRED WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS THAT
ET WITH AMENDMENTS SIX.
YOU AT THE MOMENT ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THREE TEN OR TWENTY SEVEN
SIX OH FIVE SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
EIGHT SIXTY TWO YOU EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE NINE NINETY ONE TEN THIRTY
SEVEN TEN NINETY SEVEN. TWELVE
THIRTY ONE WHILE SIXTY TWO YOU
FOURTEEN NINETEEN FIFTEEN ELEVEN
FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
FIFTEEN. FOR SEVENTY NINE SIX
SIXTY FOUR EIGHT OR NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT TEN THIRTEEN TWELVE EIGHTY
NINE FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE. FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE FIFTEEN NINETY SIX
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE NINE EIGHTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT AND SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT NINE.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED TO
READ AND ADOPT A AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
THE DAILY FILE. ITEM FIFTY. AB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ. AS SOME PEOPLE TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT BY SOMETHING NUMBER
GLORIA AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE'S.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA. NO
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT. THIS IS
THE REINTRODUCTION OF AB TWO
THIRTY THREE THAT PAT
S. HOUSE ON A SEVENTY THREE TO
ONE VOTE.
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT PROTECT
THE STUDENT'S RIGHT TO WEAR
CULTURAL ADORNMENTS AT
GRADUATION CEREMONIES.
IN RECENT YEARS SCHOOL BOARDS
HAVE ENFORCED A NO ADORNMENT
POLICY THAT PROHIBITS STUDENTS
FROM WEARING CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE.
ADORNMENTS AT THEIR SICK
GRADUATION CEREMONIES
FOR EXAMPLE NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS ARE ROUTINELY PREVENT
IT FROM WEARING EAGLE FEATHERS.
WHICH SYMBOLIZE PERSONAL
ACHIEVEMENT IN ONE'S OWN PASSAGE
INTO ADULTHOOD. THESE INCIDENTS
REVEAL THAT NO ADORNMENT
POLICIES PREVENT STUDENTS FROM
RECOGNIZING THEIR CULTURAL
HERITAGE WHILE CELEBRATING THIS
SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL MILESTONE.
NOW SPEAKER CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
STATE COMPRISED OF STUDENTS OF
VARIOUS ETHNIC RELIGIOUS AND
CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS. BY
PROTECTING A PUPILS RIGHT TO
WEAR CULTURE ENVIRONMENT.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE MR GLORIA
YOUR FULL ATTENTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAN SPEAKER.
BY PROTECTING THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO WEAR CULTURAL ADORNMENTS AT
COMMENCEMENT AB TWELVE FORTY
ENHANCES THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION. TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE I INTEND
TO ONCE AGAIN SAT DOWN WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO NEGOTIATE LANGUAGE
THAT APPROPRIATELY BOUNCES
STUDENTS RIGHTS TO FREE
EXPRESSION WITH THE SCHOOLS
RIGHTS TO PREVENT DISRUPTION
FROM GRADUATION CEREMONIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THEY DO NOT A SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
GRADUATION CEREMONIES MARK THE
CULMINATION OF ACADEMIC SUCCESS
IT IS ALSO A TIME FOR THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY GOVERNING BOARD
TO DETERMINE THE FOCUS OF THE
CEREMONIES ON ACADEMIC HONORS
AND ACHIEVEMENT. I AM A HUGE
PROPONENT OF LOCAL CONTROL AND
FREEDOM OF SPEECH WHILE THE
AUTHOR MAY ALLUDE TO IT THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT FREEDOM OF
SPEECH. IN FACT THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION ALREADY PROTECT THE
FREE EXERCISE OF RELIGION
INCLUDING WEARING RELIGIOUS
ARTICLES BY STUDENTS.
IN FACT THIS BILL IS IDENTICAL
TO AB TWO THIRTY THREE OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AS THE AUTHOR STATED
WHICH MADE IT THROUGH BOTH
HOUSES BUT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR. BECAUSE OF THESE
PROTECTIONS ALREADY EXISTS.
MADAM SPEAKER PERMISSION TO READ
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE A
WELL ESTABLISHED.
RIGHT TO EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS
THROUGH SYMBOLIC ACTS UNDER THE
STATE EDUCATION CODE AND THE
FREE CLIP SPEECH CLAUSE OF THE
FIRST A MEMBER OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION.
UNDER THESE PRECEDENTS
STUDENT EXPRESSION IS CLEARLY
PROTECTED TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS A DISPUTE. ABOUT WHAT A
STUDENT CAN WEAR AT SCHOOL
GRADUATION CEREMONIES I BELIEVE
THAT THOSE CLOSEST.
TO THE PROBLEM.
PRINCIPALS AND DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS ARE IN THE
BEST POSITION TO MAKE WISE
JUDGMENTS.
MEMBERS I'M NOT OPPOSED TO THE
CONCEPT OF THIS BILL. IN FACT
IDEA HAPPY TO.
VOTE FOR SIMILAR KIND OF
CONCEPT IF I WAS STILL A MEMBER
THE HUNTINGTON BEACH UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
TRUSTEES BUT I CANNOT VOTE FOR
THIS BILL TODAY THE WAY IT
READS.
IT IS LIKELY A RESULT THAT
NUMEROUS LAWSUITS ADMINISTRATORS
SEEK TO MAINTAIN DIGNITY AT
GRADUATION CEREMONIES BY
ALLOWING SOMEONE DORMANT
ADORNMENTS.
WHILE RESTRICTING OTHERS
FOR EXAMPLE.
MANY AMERICANS MAY REGARD A
CONFEDERATE FLAG AS A SYMBOL OF
RACISM. WHILE OTHERS MAY VIEW IT
AS A SYMBOL OF SOUTHERN HERITAGE
AND MAY ABUSE THIS LAW IN ORDER
TO ENCOURAGE THAT OR MORE
INFLAMMATORY SYMBOLS AND A
GRADUATION CEREMONY.
WELL THAT MAY BE CULTURAL TO
SOME MAY NOT BE OFFENSIVE TO
OTHERS AND WILL DISTRACT FROM
WHAT'S THE STUDENTS.
PARENTS AND ACADEMIA ARE THERE
TO ACTUALLY CELEBRATE THE AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THEIR GRADUATION.
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY
GOVERNMENT BOARDS SCHOOL BOARDS
SHOULD BE THE ONES TO ENSURE THE
FOCUS OF THE CEREMONIES IS ON
ACADEMIC HONORS AND ACHIEVEMENT.
NOT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK THAT THIS CAN
BE SOLVED BY OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS. AS AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR HAS AN EXCELLENT POINT
IS VETO MESSAGE I URGE A VOTE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD NOT A SPEAKER AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE OF MINE TO
BEACH FIRST COMMENTS I MENTIONED
EARLIER MY COMMENTS AT THIS
PREVIOUSLY PASSED THE HOUSE A
SEVENTY THREE TO ONE A LEADER TO
GUESS WHO THE ONE WAS. A WHO
VOTED OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
IT WAS STATED THAT THIS BILL
DOES IS AYE IS REDUNDANT TO
EXISTING LAW.
BUT I WOULD TELL YOU THAT YOU
SHOULD ASK THE STUDENTS FROM
PECHANGA.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHO
DIDN'T WHO ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
WEAR EAGLE FEATHERS AT THEIR
GRADUATION ASK THEM IF THE LAW
IS CLEAR ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO
WEAR CULTURAL ADORNMENTS AT
GRADUATION CEREMONIES ASKED THE
YOUNG MAN JUST DOWN THE ROAD EL
GROWTH. WHO'S DENIED CULTURAL A
IT WOULD THE ABILITY TO WEAR HIS
CAN TAKE OFF AT HIS GRADUATION
CEREMONY I HAVE THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR OUR GOVERNOR BUT THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT IS INVOLVED IN
EVERY ONE OF OUR SCHOOLS. THIS
HAPPENS REGULARLY AND IT
DESERVES CLARIFICATION BY THIS
BODY THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
ENTITLED TO FREE EXPRESSION WITH
THE CAVIAR OF NOT BEING
DISRUPTIVE AND I WOULD SIMPLY
SAY THIS IS ABOUT CULTURAL
ADORNMENTS THIS IS NOT ABOUT
POLITICAL.
OR OTHER THERE IS A REFERENCE
TO CONFEDERATE FLAG FOR WHICH I
DON'T BELIEVE I CAN TAKE CLOTH
AN EAGLE FEATHER.
IOMEGA ANY THESE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE SEE CURRENTLY IN SO MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IS.
WOULD NOT BE WOULD WE BE
PERMITTED IT WOULD NOT BE
PERMITTED THE IDEA IS TO CLARIFY
THE LAW TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO
ENJOY THEIR GRADUATION
CEREMONIES WITHOUT LITIGATION I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS BODY CAN
SUPPORT. WHO WANTS SEVERAL
LAWSUITS WE SHOULDN'T DO THAT
YOU VOTED FOR THIS PREVIOUSLY
PLEASE VOTE TO PASS THIS BILL
AND I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
SUPPORT?
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE
THE
ROLE A TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE.
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING
ITEMS FIFTY ONE THREE FIFTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
TO RECOGNIZE THE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS.
IT IS WHAT THE AT MOST SASS
SADNESS AND SORROW THAT I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF TWENTY ONE INDIVIDUALS WHO
DIED AS THE RESULTS OF THE MUD
SLIDES THAT OCCURRED IN MINUS
SETO.
A SMALL COMMUNITY IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY.
MY HEART BREAKS EVERY DAY AS WE
HEAR MORE TRAGIC STORIES.
THE MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
THAT WE LOST RANGE IN AGES FROM
THREE TO EIGHTY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
THEY WERE SWEPT AWAY IN A
TORRENT OF MUD IN THE EARLY
MORNING HOURS OF JANUARY NINTH.
TAKING TWENTY ONE INDIVIDUALS
AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOMES
FROM US.
TODAY TWO PEOPLE REMAIN MISSING
A TWO YEAR OLD AND A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD.
FAMILIES HAVE LITERALLY BEEN
RIPPED APART AS SEVERAL VICTIMS
IN THIS LENGTHY LIST ARE
RELATED.
PARENTS ARE BEARING MULTIPLE
CHILDREN.
AND CHILDREN ARE BEARING BOTH OF
THEIR PARENTS.
THE DEVASTATION IS OVERWHELMING
AND HAS TOUCHED EVERYONE IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND BEYOND.
A THREE GENERATION FAMILY LIVED
HERE. AND AT LEAST ONE FROM EACH
OF THAT GENERATION HAS BEEN
KILLED.
A GRAND MOTHER AND HER DAUGHTER
IN LAW ONLY SAVED BY WORKING THE
NIGHT SHIFT AT A LOCAL GROCERY
STORE.
THEIR SPOUSES GONE.
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN DEAD
AND STILL MISSING.
WE LOS LONGTIME RESIDENTS OF
MINE A SITO AND IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARRIVED JUST IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
WE LOST A REAL TERM A LANDSCAPER
A CAR SALESMAN.
A RESTAURANT OWNER A TEACHER A
NAVY THAT. AND TOO MANY K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS.
THAT EVENT THAT HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS A
TWO HUNDRED YEAR EVENT MEANING
SOMETHING OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
HAS NOT OCCURRED OR A CRUDE SO
RARELY IT ONLY HAPPENS IN A ONCE
EVERY TWO HUNDRED YEARS.
ONE CAN ONLY HOPE AND PRAY THAT
SOMETHING OF THIS MAGNITUDE
SPARES US.
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL LIFETIMES.
THERE ARE SO MANY STORIES OF
INSPIRATION.
HOWEVER THOSE THAT ARE WAR AROSE
FROM DESPAIR.
A MAN WHO WHILE ESCAPING WITH
HIS WIFE.
WITH A FIRE FIRE.
I HEARD A CRYING VOICE AND
PULLED OUT IN THE THICK OF MUD
SLEDGE.
A BABY.
BURIED FOUR FEET DEEP UNDER MUD
AND DEBRIS.
TANGLED IN TREE ROOTS.
THE BABY IS RISK RECOVERING
SAFELY IN THE HOSPITAL. WITH ONE
SURVIVING RELATIVE HIS FATHER.
THE U. S. COAST GUARD PERFORMING
A HELICOPTER RESCUE OF A FINE
FAMILY OF FIVE INCLUDING A
NEWBORN. TWO SMALL CHILDREN AND
THEIR DOGS.
A MOM IN HER TWO SONS TRAPPED ON
A MATTRESS AND IN A MANNER THAT
CAN ONLY BE DESCRIBED AS
SURFING.
MIRACULOUSLY LANDED ON A
NEIGHBOR'S ROOF SAFELY.
THESE STORIES ARE COUNTLESS.
AND SHOW THE RESILIENCY AND
RESOLVE OF OUR DISTRICT.
FROM THE FIRES TO THE MUD.
WE ARE EIGHT OH FIVE STRONG.
I ASK YOU TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF THE TWENTY ONE VICTIMS
OF THE MONTESINOS MUD SLIDES.
JOSEPH FRANCIS BLACK GOLD AGE
EIGHTY SEVEN.
NOT BEING CABINET AMMONIA US AGE
FORTY EIGHT.
DAVID CANTON AGE FORTY NINE.
MORGAN CRISTINA CORY TWENTY FIVE
AND HER SISTER SAWYER COREY
TWELVE.
PETER FULLER AT. AGE SEVENTY
THREE.
JOSEPHINE DOUR EIGHT SIXTY NINE.
JOHN.
MATHEMATICAL.
AGE SIXTY ONE.
ALICE MITCHELL.
AGE SEVENTY EIGHT AND HER
HUSBAND JAMES MITCHELL. EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE.
MARK MONTGOMERY AGE FIFTY FOUR.
AND HIS DAUGHTER CAROLINE
MONTGOMERY AGE TWENTY TWO.
THAT ANY THIS FAMILY.
MARILYN THOMAS TWENTY SEVEN.
KALEY BENEATH THIS HER DAUGHTER
AGE THREE.
FIVE YOUR LAB ANY DESK OF THAT
ON.
AGE TWENTY EIGHT AND HER SON
DONIPHAN BENEATH THIS AGE TEN.
REBECCA RISKIN.
AGE SIXTY ONE.
ROY RIDER AGE EIGHTY FOUR.
YOU NEED ONLY SUTA TAPI AGE
THIRTY.
PIRATA PASTA TO THE TOP BE.
SIX HIS SON.
RICHARD LORING TAYLOR. EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN.
STEP FATHER.
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF THESE MONIES SEAT OF VICTIMS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MOAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE THEY
* BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF LUCY AND WALKER.
MS WALKER WAS BORN ON OCTOBER
THE FOURTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY
THREE IN BIRMINGHAM ALABAMA.
IN HER DON'T YEARS HE RELOCATED
TO SEE LOCAL RELOCATED TO
COMPTON.
OF CALIFORNIA PURCHASED A HOME
IN ALSO CARSON. WHICH SHE LIVED
FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
SHE OBTAINED HER BACHELOR'S
DEGREE FROM THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH AND HER
MASTER'S DEGREE FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY MINGUS HILLS. AND SHE
CONTINUED EDUCATION RECEIVE A
CERTIFICATE OF COMPLETION AS
SIGN LANGUAGE FROM EL CAMINO
COLLEGE.
WITHIN HER DIVERSE CAREER PATH
SHE WAS ALSO A LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOR AN ATTORNEY.
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
SEASON EXECUTIVE SECRETARY FOR
THE CITY MANAGER'S OFFICE OF
CITY OF COMPTON.
AN ASSISTANT VICE PRESIDENT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WHICH
SOLVES JEW UNIVERSITY OF MEDICO.
THE MEDICINE AND SCIENCE.
SHORTLY AFTER RETIRING SHE
SOUGHT AFTER A SU SALTS FOUGHT
FOUGHT AFTER FOR HER SERVICES
SHE SERVED AS OFFICE MANAGER.
FOR DR ISIDORE HALT A THIRD
DURING HIS TENURE AS A STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND A SENATOR.
MS WALKER LEFT US ON JANUARY THE
FOR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
LEAVING BEHIND A SON.
ALSO A GRANDDAUGHTER.
AND A GREAT GRANDSON ALONG WITH
A WHOLE HOST OF FAMILY AND
FRIENDS TO CHERISH HER MEMORY
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
POSTERS AREN'T IN MEMORY OF LUCY
AND WALKER.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ARISE TO JOURNAL MEMORY OF
ELAINE CLOCK.
A DEVOUT SUPPORTER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
ELAINE WHO WAS BORN A PASADENA
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
PASSED AWAY LAST SEPTEMBER AFTER
BRIEF ILLNESS.
AS A LONGTIME RESIDENT OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ELAINE WAS LEADER
INTER COMMUNITY DEDICATED TO THE
SUCCESS.
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
CHOOSE A DRIVING FORCE WITHIN
THE WHIM THE I'M SORRY
REPUBLICAN WOMEN FEDERATED.
AND HEAVILY INVOLVED WITH THE
PASADENA REPUBLICAN CLUB.
EVERY ELECTION CYCLE LANE WOULD
RUN THE PAST IN REPUBLICAN
HEADQUARTERS.
THE PROVIDED MENTORSHIP FOR
COUNTLESS VOLUNTEERS OVER THE
YEARS.
ELAINE DEVOTED HER HER LIFE.
TO HER FAMILY. AND TO HER
CHURCH.
SHE WAS THE PROUD MAN OF SIX
GRANDCHILDREN FOR GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY A BROTHER
JAMES HAVE LIKE.
AND OUR CHILDREN BECKY LOYAL AND
LAUREN.
I AM PROUD AND I WISH TO HONOR
ELAINE STRENGTH COURAGE AND
DEDICATION TO BECAUSE SHE
BELIEVED HIM.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY GONNA MEMBER TODAY.
AND PASSING ALONG OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
WHO RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND.
GREAT COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER FRANCES JEAN
GRICE.
FRANCIS WAS CONSISTENTLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT MAKING HER
COMMUNITY A BETTER PLACE.
SHE CAME TO SAN BERNARDINO FROM
DETROIT IN DECEMBER OF. NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO WITH HER SON AND
DAUGHTER.
NOT ONLY MADE SAN BERNADINE KNOW
HER HOME.
BUT ALSO MADE SANDRA DINO A
BETTER PLACE.
KNOWING THAT EDUCATION WAS A
CENTER OF SUCCESS
FRANCIS SPENT MUCH OF HER TIME.
ADVOCATING FOR EDUCATIONAL
QUALITY IN SAN BERNARDINO
SCHOOLS.
SHE KNEW THAT SEPARATE WAS NOT
EQUAL.
WE JUST WHY SHE HELPED LEAD THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AGAINST SO
SCHOOL SEGREGATION.
TAKING THE CASE
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
WHERE SHE WON.
THIS LED TO HER AND OTHER
ADVOCATES ORGANIZING THE
COMMUNITY LEAGUE OF MOTHERS.
A GROUP WHICH LED THE MOVEMENT
TO INTEGRATE SANDRA DINO
SCHOOLS.
FRANCES DIDN'T STOP THERE WHEN
HE CAME TO THE BETTERMENT OF HER
COMMUNITY.
SHE UP SHE WAS ALSO A LEADER IN
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
DEPENDENCY PREVENTION PROGRAM.
A POVERTY PROGRAM WHICH IS NOW
THE COMMUNITY ACTION PARTNERSHIP
OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
FRANCIS'S COMMITMENT TO HER
COMMUNITY WAS ENDLESS.
SHE WAS A TIRELESS SPOT FOUNDER
OF OPERATION SECOND CHANCE.
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON INCORPORATING STUDENTS AS
YOUNG AS FOURTEEN INTO THE
ECONOMIC SUCCESS OF THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY.
ANOTHER FRANCIS IS PROUD
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WAS A TRIP TO
WASHINGTON DC WHERE SHE
CONVINCED DECISION MAKERS TO
NAME SAN BERNARDINO. THE ALL
AMERICAN CITY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX.
I HAD THE DISTINCT HONOR AND
PLEASURE OF SITTING WITH FRANCES
FOR COUNTLESS HOURS.
TAKING NOTES OF HER LIFE AND
LEADERSHIP.
SHE BEGAN TO WRITE HER BOOK.
HER COLLECTION OF PHOTOS FROM
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
WHICH SHE LED AN SANDRA DINO ARE
PRICELESS.
AND WE HOPE WILL SOON BE PART OF
A PICTORIAL BOOK.
FRANCES UNDOUBTEDLY GAVE HER
MORE THAN SHE EVER RECEIVED WHAT
CAN BE TESTIFIED BY THE MYRIAD
OF COLLEGE STUDENTS SHE MEANT
TOWARD.
ILLUSTRATED BY HER LEADERSHIP IN
THE RENOVATION OF THE MARKET
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
STATUE.
AND THE EXAM AND EXEMPLIFIED
THROUGH THE PERSISTENT
INVOLVEMENT AND LEVELLAND
BAPTIST CHURCHES SCHOLARSHIP
COMMITTEE.
FRANCIS LOST BOTH HER CHILDREN
DURING HER ACTIVIST YEARS.
BUT AS PASTOR CHUCK SINGLE TEN
OFTEN TOLD HER.
THEY ARE NOT LOST
BECAUSE YOU KNOW. WHERE THEY
ARE?
FRANCES IS SURVIVED BY HER
SISTER'S STEPSISTERS NIECES AND
NEPHEWS COUSINS FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WHO ALL HAVE
BEEN TOUCHED BY THE LIFETIME OF
DEDICATED SERVICE FRANCIS HAS
PROVIDED?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
MOVING NOW TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
THURSDAY JANUARY TWIT TWENTY
FIFTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE
THIRTY A. M. MEMBERS IS A
REMINDER THAT THIS THURSDAY WILL
BE THE GOVERNOR STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS.
AND THIS LAST WEEKEND WAS MISTER
KALRA BIRTHDAY MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN MISS REACHING MISTER
KALRA VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES AND MISS
BAKER SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FIFTH AT
NINE THIRTY A. M..
A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED